nice horn is not sure where he can call
home his parents left Afghanistan 35
years ago in search of a better life in
neighboring Pakistan the 27 year old is
a tailor in Islamabad and also works in
a vegetable market he barely makes three
u.s. dollars a day life is hard but at
least his family now live in relative
safety
Yahya masha'Allah the Wahhabi we have
problems in both Pakistan and
Afghanistan in different ways
here the police had asked us but the law
and order situation in Afghanistan is
not good either
there are diced Palvin and other
terrorists there who keep bombing and
killing people what can we do we cannot
live there here we have to give the
police a few dollars to get by but at
least there is no threat to our lives
relations between the two countries have
deteriorated in recent years Kabul and
Islamabad blame each other for terrorist
attacks on either side of the border and
recently human rights groups accused
authorities here of harassing refugees
giving them no choice but to go back to
Afghanistan these refugees in Islamabad
live in poverty and makeshift slums they
complain of little or no help from the
Pakistani government in fact allegations
of abuse and intimidation have increased
since last year when all Awan refugees
were ordered to leave more than 600,000
were repatriated in 2016 alone this
despite the dangers they may face on
their return the UN says it's monitoring
the situation there were issues of
harassment and pressure in some regions
by local authorities there is no doubt
and unit C has acknowledged this worked
with the government raised these issues
with the Pakistani government at the
federal level at the provincial level
but we do not agree that this amounted
to forced repatriation on a mass scale
Pakistan's command says any disputes
with Afghanistan are not driving its
refugee policy we have had our ups and
downs with the government of Afghanistan
on political bases and they have been
disagreements on certain points but we
have ensured one thing
that the refugee issue does not fall in
within that mandate or within that
scenario where you have problems with
the two between the two governments so
it's a humanitarian issue the United
Nations is also involved with us on the
humanitarian grounds refugees like
Nate's and his family are legally
allowed to stay in Pakistan until
December 31st they are hoping the
government's approach will soften but
uncertainty and inside you over what the
future holds for them continuous